we should probably announce our plans
for how we're moving forward yes with
all of this right so you know we we
tiger belly we want to get back to our
normal routine and get everyone together
in the same area to room and we also
want to get guests back in here not
through zoom because there is a
difference it just there's a disconnect
there energy yeah in terms of energy I
miss you guys too
so what we took the garage where we
painted the walls we're creating the
garage as the new space so what we're
recording we're recording in this room
this will be something else yeah because
this room is I don't know if you're able
to see it on camera but it's very tight
so we wouldn't be able like and plus if
we have like a B cam person a guest
George Gilbert me Bobby that's what like
six people in a room in a very very
tight room just breathing and talking
for for an hour and a half so we decided
to move everything in our in the garage
like old-school podcasting our garage is
is very spacious everyone gets to be
like 10 feet apart so you know cuz I
know the first guest I want to get on is
David Spade he's on the you know and I
don't want to do Spade through zoom so I
want to get him in in I know steve-o is
on the list to do it he really wants to
come in so I mean there's a big group of
people that I want to do live and I and
so we're just converting the garage so
that we can go back to our old ways you
know so that we can have some space so
we can stay stay six feet away from
people and you know this we're gonna
have to live in a world with this virus
out there and it's a scary thought but
that's just the way it is I have to
accept it so we're gonna do everything
we can so that we can go back to our all
the ways of doing things but um we want
to thank our listeners through these
hard times it's been difficult times you
know we need an alien invasion
that's what we're trying to say we need
an alien invasion
you're a [ __ ] alien arrival yes yes
something like that we need some sort of
in you know extraterrestrial intelligent
life form either aggressive or friendly
to come down that will unite the planet
because all this stuff is [ __ ] we're
the same [ __ ] species right we're all
a product of our environment so we you
know we're gonna be conditioned
conditioned conditioned is the right
word to think a certain way okay and we
need some sort of external event to
unite us because obviously a disease
isn't doing it you know obviously racial
inequality isn't doing it you know and
and we just need something to unite the
planet maybe I think 2020 has seen
enough if we can just save the alien
invasion for 2021 that would be really
for the next four years
just like you roll it out slowly like if
you're gonna send aliens like send one
or two don't send like the whole team
yet just like slow it down look at the
time
yeah they give us the you know like a
predator like one predator hunting
that'd be cool predator like the movie
oh yeah right you can see a beam a light
coming through a tree you know who's
gonna be in my who's gonna be an ally to
me Oh Leonard never more he's gonna be
my [ __ ] is a crow gonna do to [ __ ] my
[ __ ] drone you know eat daddy do you
know that a crow is essentially a drone
and he's gonna feed information back to
okay now we're talking about [ __ ]
Lord of Indiana Game of Thrones [ __ ]
Gilbert did you have a question sure